pepsi and coke mac and pc these are  brands that just don't cross over but it  looks like Microsoft wants to start  mixing things up online with their rival  Sony and the first game to support this  new venture is rocket league microsoft  announced it will support cross-platform  play between xbox one windows 10 and  quote other online multiplayer networks  it will be up to the teams at places  like steam and playstation if they want  to support this but Microsoft has left  an open invitation rocket League will be  the first game to let Xbox one users  play with others on Windows 10 the same  way that rocket League on ps4 can match  up with players on PC seems like a  pretty big deal if this venture is  successful rocket League could be the  first of many games to cross the front  line of the console wars stay tuned to  gamespot as the story develops and for  all the Microsoft and Sony news you're  already in the right place